how's it going everybody a lot of people
have been really stoked since the Shazam
trailer came out I know I'm one of those
people and I'm really starting to get
hyped up for this movie coming out I
actually think it's gonna be a really
good movie in the middle of all this
excitement I've come to find that
actually a lot of people don't know too
much about Shazam so in this video we're
going to be talking about what Shazam
actually means that's right it actually
stands for something and what his powers
are to start off let's talk about houses
am actually obtains his Superman like
powers in order for the teenager Billy
Batson to access the powers of Shazam he
must invoke the name of the wizard
Shazam so he must say the word Shazam by
doing this he summons the spells and
energies of extra dimensional beings
once known as the gods on earth when
Billy Batson invokes this spell in order
to call upon these powers a burst of
supernatural thunder and lightning
strike the ground turning the little kid
into the hero Shazam so who are these
so-called gods on earth and what are
their powers well actually each letter
in the word Shazam stands for one of the
gods s for the wisdom of Solomon H for
the strength of Hercules a for the
stamina of Atlas Z for the power of Zeus
a for the courage of Achilles and M for
the speed of mercury so let's go over
each of these gods on earth and the
powers that they give to Shazam s for
the wisdom of Solomon Solomon was an
ancient king and according to the Bible
God blessed him with supernatural wisdom
so King Solomon gives Shazam superhuman
knowledge which gives him the ability to
have a photographic memory decipher
hieroglyphics solve any mathematical
equation he can recall anything that
he's ever learned he has the gift of
clairvoyance which gives him the ability
to be aware of any situation that there
is the gift of hypnosis being able to
hypnotize people through his power and
magic and he can speak any human
language and can even understand aliens
h4 the strength of Hercules this one's
pretty self-explanatory
he's read
strong he even arm-wrestled Superman and
neither of them won they did it to a
stalemate so that's how strong is given
that Hercules is the son of Zeus it
makes sense that he gets massive
strength from him a for the stamina of
Atlas atlas was actually a Titan and had
limitless endurance this ability gives
him superhuman stamina basically meaning
that he could fight essentially forever
and he can find an endless battle such
as he did with Black Adam this also
gives him self sustenance meaning he
doesn't need to eat sleep or breathe
that's right he could survive in space Z
for the power of Zeus Zeus was the Greek
god of all gods he was father to all the
other gods out there so he gets a lot of
powers from Zeus including the ability
to summon lightning this is why he turns
into an adult because the power of Zeus
physically enhances him this also
increases his invulnerability to magic
making it to where he is only affected
by the most powerful spells along with
that comes the ability of casting
magical spells Zeus's lightning being
one of them and he can actually use the
lightning to heal himself a for the
courage of Achilles Achilles was a great
Greek hero who was known for his bravery
and spirit this ability gives Shazam the
power of bravery and courage much needed
when you're fighting somebody like
Superman him for the speed of mercury
mercury was a Greek and Roman messenger
his powers give Shazam the ability of
superhuman speed this allows him to
travel faster than the speed of light he
can even travel at speeds faster than
Mach 10 which is two miles a second and
of course this ability gives him the
power to fly does he seem a little
opiate Shazam is no joke and he even
goes head to head with Superman so I'm
really excited for the movie especially
after the trailer it looks amazing and I
think they're gonna do a good job with
it I'm really excited so that is it for
what Shazam stands for and all the
powers that he has what do you all think
about the powers of Shazam and what did
you think about the trailer that came
out let me know in the comments below be
sure to hit that like button and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up
today with all things with Shazam DC
Marvel and everything superhero thank
you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you